Where is the
nearest coffee shop?
Where can I get
cheap gas nearby?
What time is the next bus?
If your Android app knows the
user's location and context,
it can offer the most
relevant help and information
in the moment.
Take the location
and contacts course
built by Udacity
in Google to learn
how to update your Android app
to detect the user's location
and activity to offer the best
possible experience-- no matter
where the user is, no
matter what they're doing.
Learn how to use the
Fused Location Provider
to get the current location.
Delve into Activity
Recognition to tailor your app
to what the user is doing.
Learn how location services
work alongside Geofences
to allow you to
build apps that could
be used for augmented reality.
Get started now.
Your users are waiting.
For more information
visit udacity.com/google.